Marisol Morales makes a living in Havana
by lining up at the market to buy food
and other items for other people
become a paid job in this Caribbean
Nation amid chronic shortages of food
and medicine and the lines get longer
every day
there was no ground beef
thrived and as things arrive you come
we come here with a card where it's all
written what we get it's very difficult
for everyone
hardship is everywhere in Cuba these
days and experts say it will have a
major impact on the legislative
elections happening Sunday
coupons are voting for 470 members of
the National Assembly that will serve
for a period of five years and this is
happening in the middle of a severe
economic crisis where the inflation rate
this year has been over 60 percent and
with the economy ravaged by a U.S trade
embargo since 1962 the majority of the
population in this country is struggling
and the government tolerates no dissent
and that's why all eyes are going to be
on the extension rate because it's the
only way people have to express their
discontent in the last municipal
election 31 percent of the population
did not vote and many are expecting that
figure to be much higher this time
for many inflation constant power
blackouts and the Detention of hundreds
of anti-government protesters in July
2021 make this the most complex election
since the collapse of Cuba's main
benefactor the Soviet Union in 1993.
hundreds of thousands of people have
left the country heading to the U.S
Spain and other nations
says the situation is difficult for
everyone
the situation is tense we have needs of
many things I am 81 years old and I
don't think this will change
the government blames the most recent
crisis on Trump era sanctions and the
covid-19 pandemic economies say the
government has failed to transform the
state-dominated economy
the country needs a market that doesn't
need to be a market economy but Cuban
socialism the example is that a Vietnam
and China we need to have an example of
a one-party system that has managed to
survive
the government is urging people to vote
promising greater reforms that will
improve their lives but many here have
stopped believing that real change will
happen anytime soon Cuba